[Music]
thank
you thank you Biden says farewell to
sanity while Trump chills with Hannity
during a fundraiser in Boston President
Biden admitted he might not have sought
reelection if Trump wasn't in the race
said Joe quote if Trump wasn't running
I'm not sure I'd be running Joe for the
sake of your hip I'm not sure you should
even be
walking forget a campaign Joe barely Has
the strength to run a fever but after
all those wise words the president
concluded with thank you Chicago and he
said he hoped their Dolphins would win
this year's Stanley
Cup then during a town hall with Hannity
in Iowa Trump was Trump and by that I
mean his usual hilarious self unlike
Biden though he was hilarious because of
what he said not because he kept shaking
hands with Casper the Friendly
Ghost but when it comes to Biden lasting
until the election I wonder if Trump
personally thinks he makes it a person
personally don't think he makes it I
think he's in bad shape physically do
you remember when he said I'd like to
take him behind the barn if he took me
behind the barn and I went like
this I believe he'd fall over I believe
he'd fall over who knows who know I'm
surprised there's no headlines that read
Trump wants to blow Biden behind a
barn terrible sick people but did he
ever watch him at the beach I watched
him at the beach he wasn't able to lift
a beach chair which is meant for
children to lift you could lift him like
that uh and mentally I would say he's
possibly equally as bad and maybe
worse Trump also touched on the
indictments he's facing once again
likening himself to Al Capone but was he
one of the greatest of all time Al
Capone he was one of the greatest of all
time if you like criminals he was a mop
boss to lik of which Scarface they call
him and he got indicted once I got
indicted four
times classic Trump you know uh the most
famous gangster of all time you got one
IND diment I got
four then there was this moment when
Trump was asked about the media painting
him as a dictator under no circumstances
you are promising America tonight you
would never abuse power as retribution
against anybody except for day one
except he's going crazy except for day
one meaning I want to close the border
and I want to drill drill that's not
that's not
retribution we love this guy he says
you're not going to be a dictator are
you I said no no no other than day one
we're closing the border and we're
drilling drilling drilling after that
I'm not a dictator okay that that sounds
to me like you're going back to the
policies when you were
president well
it we
go of course it wouldn't be Trump if he
didn't say something to make heads spin
like a barn owl on meth but mark my
words the media will interpret this As
Trump declaring Marshall Law and
naturally the media's been wetting
themselves over that moment speaking of
wetting themselves anything to add Joe
yeah you heard him he's the dictator day
one dictator he's going to close the
border and I open the border right
that's what I did day one open the B
Good Guys open things take ators close
things everybody knows that I like
opening things you know Windows uh
refrigerators uh car
doors I can't open jars though you're
too
tight I have Jill do it for me she's
tough Jill she got her doctorate in kung
fu gripy it's a true story that's not a
joke
[Applause]
Kurt how do you see this going forward
over the year I mean you just listening
to Trump you you get when you get a dose
you can't help but laugh well look if I
was a insurance underwriter I'd be very
very depressed about Joe Biden right now
this guy is old he is methusa old he is
riding dinosaurs old uh he is a Crusty
desicated old pervert who was stupid to
begin with and now he's scile and
that's kind of going easy on him he's
he's a terrible person in every way and
this stuff about being Trump being a
dictator you know it would be terrible
if Trump went out and oh I don't know
persecuted his political enemies and
tried to silence them that would be
awful now I you know Trump would launch
an attack on
Democracy um I'm not uh look I'm from
California so I don't understand
democracy because we have Gavin
Nome I'm just worried that you know Joe
Biden's going to wander off chasing an
imaginary
squirrel and be replaced with Gavin Nome
and he's going to run on the slogan I'm
going to make California or make America
just like California and have a hobo in
every pot
so yeah I hate hobos Tyrus do you I'm a
hobosexual do you know any I'm a
hobophobic yeah and a hobosexual yeah I
think you're right the first time there
geld hobosexual is a real thing yeah it
is we literally the little guy on the
show like every other week glasses I
thought you're talking about me no
little bigger little guy medium little
guy yeah listen this is uh a brilliant
scheme by Biden which is for me to say
that hurts my face but he's saying I
have to run to stop Trump so he's
creating the monster even though I'm old
I'm tired I'm senile I have to to save
this country right and all his
surrogates are out there democracy so
Trump's the new he's Hitler 2.5 and he's
going to do all the things that they
accused him of doing that ironically
they do but he that way he'll be like
I'm not debating a dictator I'm not
debating Trump he's a criminal so he's
laying the thing he's not going to be in
the basement he's going to be in the sun
room so he'll be able we'll be to look
at him through the window and he'll be
like nope not doing it because look who
he is and so this is actually a I don't
know who came up with it they must have
hired an angry Republican but this is
their plan and this is how he's gonna
lay it out so there'll be no debate
because he can't debate president Trump
that I mean my what he have to arrest
Trump for abuse if they had a debate
which they might do and he won't have to
he won't have to go around the country
because he has to stay and protect the
White House Trump could show up any time
and try to take the on his watch so he's
got to be there so this is actually a
pretty this is their plan this is what
we're going to see so you're going to
see Gavin Newsome on the trail Kamala on
the trail you're going to see all the Cs
on trail he's going to be at the White
House guarding it to make sure none of
trump and his minions the maggot try to
get back in so uh it's it's scary enough
to what scares me is it might work yeah
you know cat he says we can't let him
win is that the bat signal to tell
everybody everything's on the table do
what you want to stop Trump I know about
that I just know that you missed the my
the funniest thing I thought that Trump
said by far I mean everyone's talking
about the part where he said he yes
Kennedy the dumbest guy in the Senate
and he said it was Joe Biden but the
funniest part to me is he said he asked
who's the smartest guy in the Senate and
the guy gave me a name but I don't
really want to share it because I don't
like the guy at
all that is like the kind of weird cuz
every guy in this in the Senate now who
was around during that time is like was
it me was I the smart guy did Kennedy
think I was the smartest guy and they
probably all do think it was them but
that is when one of the moments where
it's so clear that Trump has this
background in reality TV because that's
exactly the kind of thing you'd see a
producer kind of plant on a Bravo show
before they all have the dinner where
they get blackout drunk together and at
each other we you know we don't deserve
him he just said I I I he gave me a name
but I'm not going to tell you cuz I
don't like the
guy Tyler how do you think Trump felt
after this do you think he was proud of
how it went man he's he's getting
funnier by the day and if you love him
or hate him give him a Netflix special I
mean it's getting hard to do impressions
of trump or make fun of them make jokes
cuz he's getting funnier I want you to
do one now though I wish frankly I just
a tease a little
tease but just a little tease day one
tease a little tease but this is the
first time in history I'm not sure our
candidates are going to make it to the
election one of them could be in jail
yeah and one of them could be dead you
know Biden could be assassinated by the
stairs at this point you know what I
mean so and if Trump Goes to Jail he'll
still run from from jail they make it
sound cool we're going to jail nobody's
going as quick as me two days right El
Choo couldn't do it alone couldn't do it
the Zodiac Killer he couldn't even do it
it took him eight days I win in two days
I wi in two days we're making shackle so
great he won't be able to do the full
he'll have to do little shackle
him very good all right hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else